you were lamenting the gig worker
economy
um and that they're being exploited i'm
curious
if you look at you know uh being a
a ride-sharing driver or delivering food
as
an entry-level you know i'm going to
work at 20 hours a week
and make whatever 12 to 20 an hour
depending on how busy it is
do you have a problem with that or do
you have a problem with it starts to tip
over into full time they should get
benefits
because it seems to me like these jobs
have already existed and nobody
complained about them but
if uber lyft and jordash become large
companies then all of a sudden it's like
well this feels unfair
well it's just exploitation on an
industrial scale and i think there are
many problems here one problem is that
no one is taking home after expenses 12
to
20 bucks an hour there's been numerous
studies on this basically everything
hinges on the fact that you convince gig
workers to run down the assets that they
have
you convince them to run down the asset
like their car defer maintenance
defer depreciation basically not
dealing with any of the costs of
actually providing the service
and so even in the best of cases or i
don't even know if it's the best case
even in the case where someone just
works 10 hours a week because they want
to make some extra cash
is utterly exploitive the fact that gig
workers are not being paid
for their expenses the fact that they're
not being paid while they're waiting
between
jobs i saw one study just come out was
it last week
about the fact that uh uber and lyft are
majorly contributing to
um congestion in cities to to traffic
because
40 of the time spent working for these
apps are spent without
passengers in the car and there's 40 of
that hours they're not being paid for
that hours
so if a freelancer though i mean you
you've worked with a lot of freelancers
or freelancers between
writing blog posts or designing logos
but they want that flexibility shouldn't
they be able to have it
and be 1099. i think i think they're or
can only rich people be 1099.
sure but i think there's just a material
categorical difference between someone
who's making
essentially no money after you account
for expenses um
or whether that makes up for it not
everyone i've ever known who've done
consulting in tech they don't charge
like
what a full-time worker would get paid
per hour
they charge what three five ten times as
much because they know
that the job and the income is lumpy so
you might have a great contract here for
for a month that's full time
great but you got to make essentially
three months pay to
to fill up your funnel and and deal with
that so it's just not at the same scale
i think
the fundamental underlying issue here is
that
geek workers as you say they should be
paid 15 20 bucks
an hour after expenses accounting for
time
spent servicing the platform and that
includes
the time driving from dropping off one
patron to to picking up the next yeah i
think nowadays
just doing that they they pay for that
time i don't think they pay for the wait
time
and there's a minimum now uh
with the 50 cents an hour or whatever 50
cents a mile
fee so i don't think you're correct in
that they're making under
what would be minimum wage in any case
because why would millions of people
then choose those jobs david if
there are so many other jobs that are
looking like why would you choose to do
this
if there are so many this is this is
desperation
when you have some it's kind of like why
would anyone ever get a payday loan you
know what the interest rates are on
payday loans they're outrageous why
would anyone ever do it
this is a multi-billion dollar industry
when you have an asset
like a car and you need cash sometimes
you will look at that equation and go
you know what it may be i'm deferring
maintenance that maybe i'm running down
my asset
but that's tomorrow today i need 80
bucks
so i'm gonna drive for uber or lyft or
doordash
even if on the long or all three i mean
they're mostly
usually multiple yeah and and then on
the long scale i'm not gonna make any
money but the long scale just doesn't
matter tomorrow
matters paying the bill that's due now
matters uh picking up groceries matter
and this is kind of the pro or praying
on the precarious that
i find just so disappointing and i find
it doubly disappointing because i
remember when uber first came out and it
was essentially
uh black cars right
and and i thought like wow what a great
idea and this was a relatively expensive
service
um because it is relatively expensive to
have a private chauffeur
right this is the other illusion we have
here is that like suddenly everyone
could afford to have private
chauffeurs private shoppers doing all
this work for them
while those workers were being well paid
and the companies turned into
multi-billion dollar companies
no no society didn't just fundamentally
change in any of those ways such that we
could all
enjoy an army of servants um
so i think that there's just there's
some fundamentals here that are
uncomfortable i think these
companies are continuing to be
unprofitable because the real product
that they have
for example getting chauffeured around
is a high-end luxury product that
people just can't afford at the scale of
its current use
that maybe there's a great uber that's a
two billion dollar company
or an 800 million dollar company or
whatever the size of it i still have a
large
black cap be careful with the valuation
talk david i still have a big piece of
that company
let's not run down the valuation just
yet okay well i think this is exactly
why
i need to talk about it right because i
don't have a piece of any of these
companies which is why i talk about
valuations in in general because i think
they're they're really important and
it's really important to
examine who owns these companies who
funds them and
and and look at like how does that maybe
buyers the view on on whether we should
have a
a broad social net or whether companies
should be required to hire people as
employees
um conversations the argument i think
for um low prices for ubers is that it
gives
uh back to the discussion about you know
people having access to stuff
it gives a larger group of people access
to actually get a ride when they need
one right
if you i lived in brooklyn in the
boroughs you couldn't get a taxi
you know you might be able to get what
they call the gypsy cab back in the day
you pay somebody under the books and an
illegal car three or four bucks to take
you somewhere
and uber does provide a really safer
much safer
tracked uh you know down to the
millisecond like where the car
is um and vetted approach than those
cabs
right and so that was progress in my
mind yeah maybe
right you saw the uber safety report
what two thousand rapes in a year
well i mean you have to understand the
denominator on these as well i mean the
denominator
is just 1.7 billion rides in a quarter
so
i think just like they're releasing
let's just
not pretend that they've solved the
inherent safety issue that is getting
into a stranger's personal car
right they have it right maybe they've
made it much safer i don't even want to
argue that point
because i i think they've made it i
think it made it much safer
uber is a better product in the user
experience yeah in user experience
and safety you admit
it has to be safer because you know
exactly where the cab is at every point
and you have
the the credit card number of the
passenger so for both parties
you have their entire history of where
they've taken people
and you have the minute by minute
location second by second location of
the car with a cab
you know you could have any people used
to share licenses in the yellow cabs and
they could drive anywhere and they're
not tracked and there's no central
dispatch
tracking it in real time where you can
press the safety button say there's a
problem
sure on remediation on following up if
there was
a great investigation into these claims
you would have more data no doubt about
it
one of the key problems with uber and
other platforms is they've been very
reluctant to do that
not only have they been reluctant to do
that they've been actively interfering
in investigations one of the main
scandals that came out before uber went
public
was when one of the senior executives
went to india to essentially
what get the medical records on a rape
victim there because it was looking bad
i think
it's just this story is very muddy on
whether yeah i think that safety is
actually there's been some regime change
there